dix neuf huit dix sept
neuf six huit cinq sept quatre six
trois cinq deux quatre un trois deux
deux mission et travail d'ascenseur l'
effort de Dieu lance à nouveau quatre
astronautes de trois pays sur l'équipage
deux
qui se dirigent maintenant vers le seul et unique
véhicule de la station spatiale internationale  est en train de descendre la gamme neuf
moteurs merlin sur la première étape
fournissant 1,7 million de livres de poussée en
entendant de bons appels pour la performance de la première
étape jusqu'à présent
30 secondes après le début de la deuxième
mission d'équipage de rotation
à bord du dragon et du faucon 9. le
faucon 9 étranglera le
neuf merlin  moteurs sous
peu ici en préparation pour
en préparation pour la pression dynamique maximale
et il y a cet appel à l'
accélérateur la pression dynamique maximale
max
q est la plus grande charge structurelle que
le véhicule voit tout au long de l'ascension,
donc la réduction nous aide à passer
la
descente supersonique nous aide à passer  à travers cette
période d'
accord un bravo est le deuxième
mode d'abandon sur la première étape
première étape  continue de tirer pendant deux
minutes 35 secondes
une minute et demie après le vol d'aujourd'hui le
faucon 9 voyage maintenant à 1500 milles à l'
heure
et les frissons du moteur ont bien
commencé le spectacle du moteur pour le
moteur merlin simple du deuxième étage a commencé
environ 30 secondes de plus du
tir du premier étage pour mettre en orbite nos quatre astronautes